i also have been encouraging major
sports teams to plan reopenings
without fans
but the games could be televised new
york state will help those major sports
franchises to do just that
[Music]
hockey basketball baseball football
whoever
can reopen we're a ready willing and
able partner sporting events pro sports
in that first
week or so of june without spectators
and modifications and very
prescriptive conditions
also can begin
to move forward
that was first andrew cuomo the governor
of the state of new york and then gavin
newsom the governor of the state of
california with some positive news about
the
the return of professional sports
california been a bit of a wild card
they've been people who were thinking
that maybe gavin newsom would maybe slow
play a little bit maybe not open
california first pro sports even without
fans present
and and
look there are plenty of conversations
happening behind the scenes this is a
very political process not political in
the red state blue state sense political
in the sense that you got to work the
phones you got to work the relationships
you got to make sure people understand
the cost and the benefits and the
alternatives and i think once gavin
newsom realized the nfl will pack up
their three california teams and move
them elsewhere for the season that
probably helped people get some clarity
in california as to whether or not
they're going to allow pro sports to
continue because they will continue in
some other state
that's right they're gonna it mean it it
seems like it's gonna happen especially
with the nfl they're steadfast on making
it happen and you know but these 32
owners and the money and power they have
and the the train in which is the nfl
you know i'm i'm not gonna not believe
them until
i have enough proof to say okay it's not
gonna happen but
i do believe them in that and yeah
you're right i mean i was worried about
california too
but also you know i think you know some
of these governors are looking at it
going okay we need to jump start the
economy it'd be nice to have all those
players there we could tax some of their
paychecks do all that of course it'll be
good for the economy in general even if
there aren't players i mean fans at the
stadium people are gonna you know go to
the stores and buy beers and buy food so
they can maybe have some family or a few
really close friends over to watch a
football game let alone it's like super
the soul you know that's the other thing
too we need it we're going crazy as a
country right now we're all going crazy
you know and all you guys i'm taking
little baby steps i actually saw two
friends yesterday that i hadn't seen in
nine weeks they've been smart we said
okay we'll bring the kids over there let
our kids play with their kids but you
know i'm about to go crazy and i think
the whole damn country is and i want
sports back just almost as medicine for
all of us to help us through this
the other good news teams are allowed to
open their facilities today if they are
in
communities that will permit it roughly
22 of the franchises
are allowed to do it but but still not
all of them are going to
uh they're taking their time they're
moving slowly the real question is when
will teams be able to reconvene for
training camp will they have training
camps in their normal facilities will
they have to go somewhere else these are
all things to be determined and there is
time but not a ton of time we're getting
toward memorial day weekend the end of
may we'll be here june will fly by i
think i think after the fourth of july
there better be some clear plans about
when training camps can open will open
and where they will open or the nfl is
going to have a hard time getting ready
for the start of the season on thursday
september 10. another thing that's come
up chris and this came from the adam
schefter podcast dr tom mayer the nfl
pa's medical director says that they
have been testing
modified face masks that contains
surgical or n95
does not surprise me at all i i thought
maybe guys would find a way to cover
their faces now maybe they're gonna
cover their face masks you know maybe
we're gonna have the old remember the
old justin tuck face mask that was that
that convoluted barbed wire thing that
you could you couldn't stick a finger
through if you wanted to right it could
be a very tight mesh metal design that
has a layer of on the inside or the
outside
protective material to keep those those
droplets to keep saliva to keep other
things from getting through into the
face of the player
yeah i mean you know listen i it sounds
smart and sure
but i mean first off i don't think
players give a damn and you just saw
that the the the hissy fit that tom
brady threw to wear a new helmet or
antonio brown now you think you're gonna
put on a face mask on those guys that's
going to cover up their good luck
getting that on tom brady at 43 years
old and hey we just watched a video big
ben throwing to james connor and juju
smith schuster listen i again i'm going
to stand by this i don't think football
players give a damn about cobia 19 and i
don't mean that to be disrespectful i'm
fearful of it and i you know but at that
age and i understand the way the the you
know the physical peak condition they're
in and hey great it's a face mask on
there that they can't breathe meanwhile
they're sweating and bleeding on each
other or you know as a quarterback you
got your finger up you know your centers
you know crack all games all right all
right so that i don't know they're going
to put a mask over his butt crack too to
take the germs away there you go there's
nothing
there may be players who have natural
concerns there's going to be a group of
guys who say we don't care
but we talked about patrick peterson
earlier in the program he's diabetic
and he knows he's diabetic what about
all the guys who don't know they're
diabetic you know yeah we hear all the
time well if you're older if you have
health conditions you you know you
should continue to stay away from people
there are plenty of folks walking around
who don't know
that they have a health condition that
leaves them at risk for a serious
outcome from the coronavirus there are
plenty of people who are diabetic who
don't know it there are plenty of people
have other conditions that don't know it
the the offensive and defensive lineman
for many teams are morbidly obese that's
a risk factor regardless of any other
health conditions they may have so there
will be guys who think hey what can i do
to protect myself but you're right i i'm
they're in the the petri dish
and i don't know that that a little
surgical mask or n95 material is going
to make a difference when you're talking
about playing a football game where guys
are constantly blocking and tackling and
and here's the other thing too and you
know how football players are chris if
there's a guy that does have the special
mask on you know there's gonna be some
guys trying to spit up under it right oh
they're gonna be able to mess with them
you you wimp you wearing that mask you
scared i mean yeah you're right they're
gonna hear it they are you know also
what i thought about mike too is
quarterbacks like hey i've had fun with
drew brees and all the ticks he has on
the field right i mean every time he
throws a pass we show a clip of him he
does this right here he licks both
fingers he grabs his shoulder pads and
pulls them down every time you know i
don't want a mask on and if i'm a
quarterback i'm sorry i'll be licking my
hand that's what i'm going to do my job
is to throw the football licking my
hands and get a little moisture helps me
throw the football better so those are
other things i just look at and go you
know just football players are such
creatures of habit i think they're going
to be bothered by some of that type of
stuff
so we'll see where it all goes it's an
interesting talk though
it's good it's going to take a real
adjustment and they've got time but not
a ton of time and hopefully they're
taking full advantage of the benefit
they have that other sports don't have
where they're able to sit back process
come up with ideas and understand and
change behaviors if they need to
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports